Monday. I got a bit of RNR yesterday.
So, the goal is going to be to close out
this release strong.
hopefully have it actually properly
tested, not forgetting any of the things
we need. Um, I'm going to start off
today
by applying just a band-aid patch to the
setup so that we can actually build
things without having to like manually
copy files around
today. Also help with uh a bunch of the
people who are kind of trying to fight
with the dev branch to keep stuff
working. We'll do that.
Um, we're going to look at our sweep
code. There's a lot of stuff that we
need to finalize on sweeps and then
likely a lot of just small environment
binding changes and integrations to make
sure all of our environments work with
dev. We've made some small CPI changes.
They're going to need to be uh things
are going to be need to be updated
for. So, we'll do that. And
um that pretty much will get us onto the
experimentation and testing
phase.
Um we're kind of just on like we're on
like sort of between the minor fixes
phase and that final testing phase. So I
want to really get us to that. I think
actually the main thing that I don't
know about there is
the probably just the
um the sweep stuff. There's still a
couple rough edges, but we'll get to
that. Let me switch the scene
view and we'll get started.
on. Let's see. Posted it here. Yes, he
did. So, let me see if this even makes
any sense.
Yeah. So, this
thing runs an additional copy. I don't
know why this doesn't happen by default.
but we can see here that it is actually
correctly copying
now. Yo, what's up Mr.
Sup? Morning
runs. Let's actually do a
full B full dash dot. Let's see if our
commands work at all.
fly. Okay. So, for some reason it's
defaulted to
3.8. We'll fix that on the container.
Can we do
um what's the uh the Nvidia Docker
containers? I'm just trying to think of
um Okay, so this is they do still ship
2204 containers. I believe 2404 is the
first Docker version where things get
stupid. I mean the first abundu version
where things get stupid. So, we can
probably just put like Python 312 on uh
what is it? The 128
container. Oh, yeah. They ship
containers with everything, huh?
this now. The only thing is we probably
want to have
um maybe two versions.
128 is like really new and your drivers
are going to be
dated. I could also just do 128 and make
an upgrade driver
script. That's also valid, right?
So, we have that issue fixed. Now, let's
do let's check on our
experiments. Check on our experiments.
Why you have two terminals running on
the same
folder? So I can do
this, right? I can run training and then
I can
like edit
here because all my all my dev is also
just in
term. So I have an edit window and
usually I have a run window.
And normally this one would be a full
size like this would be my full left
screen, but I have uh my cameras in the
way. So, I have chat on this monitor, so
it's easier for me to see without
looking over like this.
Okay. So, whatever I ran here was like
okay, but not quite as good as before,
it looks
like. Let's figure out what this was. I
think this is with resets.
Yeah, I think this is like if you reset
the end and run a very small amount of
like followup
Um, this is like a very small sample as
well.
I also don't like that we have a two
train functions. Might have to rename
some things. But uh for now here I
think Oh, hang on. This is not resetting
right.
this I don't think I've seen well I
don't know if you're if you're new to
the stream so this is I do ultra high
performant reinforcement learning
dev
so all these demos on puffer.ai these
are all simple games but written in C to
run like 10,000 times faster than you
would normally expect and uh we train AI
on these and we use these for research
in order to make the methods behind all
of this way better. So you can see all
of these in your browser and like this
is a neural net playing this game
superhuman live in your
browser. We've got multi-agent stuff
like the snake game. So if you watch
this for long enough you'll see like all
sorts of snakes
emerge. We've got like classic arcade
stuff and we've even got more complex
and interesting things like uh this
massively multi-agent environment which
has like economy and trade and resources
and equipment and all sorts of things.
So this is what I do. This is my job. Um
trying to like improve this field and
progress the science here. And I stream
all the dev because why not?
Yeah. So this chart is this is a Neptune
interface. So this is 200 experiments.
Each of these experiments is
uh that's E8. So this is up each of
these experiments is up to 600 million
steps of maze solving. So this plot has
I don't know probably
like a couple like few hundred years
worth of like games played just solving
mazes and uh the goal of this is to like
automatically find the best algorithm
settings. So like some of the
experiments we run they don't do very
well but then we have a a method that
automatically tunes the way that our
experiments are run in order to get
better results overall here.
doesn't Oh, no. Here it is. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
So there is an async reset
here. You're not going to alpha code
your way. So here's the thing. When you
use code as your
primitive, not everything if when you're
talking about code in the way that they
are, it's like scripts and classic
algorithms like classic software. Not
every problem is amendable to that. Like
for instance, if you imagine trying to
like script a bot for Dota, like a bot
to play Dota or a bot to like you know
do any sort of fiddly task often like
calibrate a machine in industry or like
optimize some process like op like the
data center cooling that they did as
well with DRL.
Um it's way better to have these
processes be fuzzy and you want a model
that can actually just output actions
directly. So it's not like one is just
better than the other. It's like they're
different. There are different use
cases. It's not even that I'm bearish on
the stuff that
um you know that's happening in language
modeling land. Like Deep Mind's doing
really cool stuff in that space as well.
It's just like I think re like deep
reinforcement learning is also really
important and comparatively like
nobody's working on it. So that's why I
do this stuff, right?
If there's an important problem and zero
other qualified people are doing it,
that's an opportunity for Okay.
right, we're going to run this. We're
going to see what this does.
Um, and if this doesn't work, then I
think that there is there's something
screwy with the hyper pram sweep
specifically that's like requiring you
to have skewed results for it to
work. Ryan does stop a little bit. I had
to take uh the better part of yesterday
off to sort of just
recover. Got a little bit of a run in,
got some lifting in. I kind of chilled
for a bit. It was good.
Um, yeah. So, I'm I think that we're
probably good to just like crank out
this release over the next few days.
That's the
goal. I got 45 minutesish, 40 minutesish
now, and then after breakfast, I will be
back for the whole rest of the day doing
So, we're going to try the m sweep one
more time.
And we're going to hope that we actually
get
um like some more reasonable stuff out
of this. But I'm going to try to monitor
this more throughout the day so we get
more runs in because really this hyper
pram stuff needs to just be done. Like
this is the only missing uh like
functionality piece is just like getting
the the default settings for hyper pram
sweeps solid. I'm going to leave this up
on the other window.
Wait, there's a release. Yeah, big
release coming as soon as I well, as
soon as I finish all the like testing
and stuff for this. All this stuff is
free and open source code, but um we
operate in like four to six month
usually release cycles. So, I only ship
two or three major big versions a year,
but like they're really large. So, like
um it's a generational leap, if you
will. Like reinforcement learning in
2.0, know it works if you automate the
hell out of it. Reinforcement learning
in 3 0 once I finish the fiddly bits
kind of just works a lot of the time out
of the
box and then hopefully by the end of the
year we get 40. Um which if that goes
the way that I hope it does uh it should
just be yet again like a completely
different field and at that point we'll
kind of be able to just solve
whatever the grind takes a small lifting
intermission break. Thanks for the
reminder.
coffee. The
uh the pressing
strength is definitely
back. Need to get
my pulling and leg strength back to
where they used to
be. The current
project. All
right.
So, let's look at
the the original maze sweep that
worked. Like, you can see these all
these like jank ones here that didn't
So based on these, I actually am
probably not going to
expect this thing to work
correctly. Let me find the good
one. Mark Rippletoe
approved.
Man, I
did He was the starting strength guy,
right? I did 5x5s for like uh maybe the
first two years and then two things kind
of happen. one, it stops working, and
two, a 5x5 once you are decently strong,
especially if you're doing any other
side sort of exercise outside of that
cuz like I run as well, it's just a
brutal thing to do like to always be
doing a
5x5. Like I do a if I do a 5x5 of
squats, that's it. I'm out for the day.
So, I had to do heavy light days for
like a year or so after that. And then I
sort of like the focus was on running
for like a year till I did my uh my
50k. Then I came back got my thousand
total and then pneumonia kicked my ass.
So, I'm still recovering from
that. Higher score. No, higher score is
good. No problem with the questions.
You're new. Um,
so what this is, let me explain what
this is. So this is a solve percentage
on the y ais. Um, and this is for mazes.
So like if I just
this. Nah, we don't have the demo file
on
Eval. Okay, so this is a random agent
solving a maze. It's not going to do
very well because it's random. So the
goal is to learn an agent that can solve
this maze. And then we randomly generate
new mazes of different sizes as well. So
the maze could be like this big, or the
maze could be the size of this whole
window here.
um down to around here. So, we're trying
to train a good maze solving agent. And
specifically, it's not that mazes are
very interesting. It's that they're a
very tough problem for RL to solve. Like
RL is can solve really, really amazing
things, but not really mazes very well.
Mazes are very hard. So, what happens is
if you're good at solving mazes, it
often is the case that your same
algorithm is going to be good at solving
a lot of other things as well, uh with
reinforcement learning specifically. So
y-axis here is the percentage of mazes
that it solves and x-axis is the number
of steps that we've trained the agent
for and then all the different graphs or
different experiment settings. So one of
these lines, this is 50 million here. So
one of these lines is an agent trained
for 50 million steps on solving mazes.
So it's basically it's made 50 million
moves within different mazes. And you
can see that we have some settings that
do very poorly and some settings that do
pretty well up here. So my goal here is
to get an algorithm uh get a setting
such that when we release puffer you can
run this thing and it should generate
you very good consistent results on
mazes and then what I do on top of that
right is I don't just do mazes right I
run it on breakout I run it on neural
MMO which is a fancy end I run it on
multi- aent stuff I run it on tons of
different things and if it does well on
all of them then that is a robust
algorithm so that is the goal And if we
are able to do that, then we will have
made a monumental difference in the
field of reinforcement learning. Uh
because this stuff kind of just doesn't
exist outside of Puffer Lib right now,
my project. Um yeah, that's our
goal. I'm trying to find the
good the good maze result.
Okay. Yeah. So, this is the one that I
was looking for. So, this is I think the
best one that we've seen so
far. How much funding do you have for
Puffer Lib? I don't take funding. We
have a few clients. Uh we charge for not
any of our code. Our code code's all
free, but we charge for priority
service. So, let's say that you're doing
reinforcement learning industry. You're
probably having a tough time of it
because it's really hard. We have the
best tech and the best tools uh to help
you solve that problem. So you can pay
us to have our eyes on your problem to
get all of our latest tools as they come
out instead of waiting for the next
release and to help steer some of our
research directions in ways that benefit
you. So we charge for that and then that
funds like servers and many of the other
things that we
need building a kind of setup for
algorithm testing. Yeah, it's a bit of
both cuz like Pufferlib is both a
toolkit for doing reinforcement learning
very very well in academia and industry,
but it's also a toolkit for advancing
reinforcement learning itself. And we
use it for
both. So the thing that I'm running into
right now, which is a little bit weird,
is this is the best set of maze
experiments that I have. And I believe
that the way that I get I got these was
that when I do my evaluations, I reset
the maze before I evaluate it and then I
run for like a small fixed number of
steps and that actually guides the
curves to be
better. Whereas with this one, it's like
the same thing except
uh I don't reset the mazes for
evaluation and then this totally screws
stuff up. Now looking at this
here, there's a big difference in the
x-axis. I'm just noticing now. Wait,
this is
5v7. Oh, okay. I think that the issue
that we're running into is just
somehow one setting is running longer
experiments than the other, which would
make a lot more
sense. Yeah. Yeah. And to new folks,
like I generally do the best job I can
kind of just narrating stuff as I'm
thinking it, but like I mean it's this
is like a research stream first and
foremost. So if you like if stuff
doesn't make sense and you're curious,
just ask questions. Like half the reason
I stream. Part of it is like it forces
me to narrate my thought process out
loud, which actually makes me more
productive than any time I spend talking
to chat anyways. So it's cool. Um, and
the other thing that's nice about this
is all of Puffer Lib's free and open
source. And like one of the main ways
that we advance the field is from open
source contributors. So like if you're
interested in working on AI stuff and
you want to learn this and you have not
even an AI background, if you just have
a programming
background, most of these environments
are written by contributors. Like most
of these are a few hundred lines. It's
basically just low-level game
development with a few extras in order
to make them work well with
reinforcement learning. So like, you
know, we have contributors that we've
onboarded that are now doing stuff that
rivals like top uh top academic labs in
RL. So if you're interested in that,
drop by the Discord, you know, or hit me
up and come build with us.
Okay, so this is performing differently
uh compared to before. It's not all
stuck on these really short runs, it
seems. So possibly this does
okay. I think we will leave this one for
like the next and probably until after
breakfast and then we'll check this
experiment. But this is like not looking
terrible just initially. Now, I do
wonder why there's so many of these like
bad runs down
here. This is a little bit
sketchy.
Um, we'll have to do some analysis on
that, but I think as a first uh first
pass, this is pretty
decent. Okay, so that checks off two of
the things uh that I wanted to get
started for this
morning. Let's go check the to-do list.
We've got all the blog post to work on.
I do not feel like doing that right
now. Uh we've got docks to finish kind
of. Maze sweeps, ablations.
I'm just looking through the list of
like things that we can that we still
have to do. I think it is mostly going
to
be just like final
huh? So I the biggest thing is probably
just going to be all the environments
need to be updated and and adjusted a
little bit.
I think that gave me some PRs that I
haven't
merged. How can you quantify how far are
we at solving the maze? Yeah, you only
solve it if you reach the end point. So
80% of the ma there's no solve 80% of
the maze. It's solving 80% of
mazes. There's some details on that, but
roughly that metric means for 80% of the
mazes that that we give you, you solve
uh you solve them. That's what it
means. More precisely, it means um if I
generate you a random maze, there's
about an 80% chance that you'll solve
it. And to be clear, like so
reinforcement learning is really not
good at mazes. Um and it's not supposed
to be. Like that's there are reasons not
to expect it to be good. So how well we
are able to do in this uh is actually a
very good indication that we just have
the best algorithm
overall because like our agent I've
shown this to other researchers in RL as
well and they're like what the heck how
are you able to do
Got Gabe has sent us a new environment
as well.
bets pushed as is
removed flash from end
He's got binding C. He got rid of the
Syon
file. He's added
us the new binding format for triple
triad. It looks
like the triple triad code is a mess. We
don't have too high of standards there.
There's the new log structure. This is
done correctly. Removes all the old
stuff. This is
fine. I believe this is good
too. Got allocate on
this into the freeze.
um he reindexed actions a little
bit. Should be fine.
Fine. New binding. Very good. And remove
this from there.
Good. Thank you. Bet. We will merge
this.
And then I believe triple triad
this. And then I believe triple triad here we can get rid of because we're
here we can get rid of because we're
removing the siphon.
conflicts. I don't see anything else.
Oh, there it
is. And then we can get rid of this
because we automated the finding of
files.
no attribute. So we have to fix the
config most
this. And now this is when we're going
to hit the new uh binding nonsense.
Holy.
So, is this free? So, this just has to
call free triple
Close. This should be defined
now. Is it not
here. Okay. Well, let's see if this
runs.
It
does. And that
trains. That like trains very well.
Perfect.
I am totally going to have to make like
a
sample or or maybe just comment like the
squared sample project.
things. Uh, that does now work
though. And if we check our
mazes, I mean, we're getting some decent
runs here, right? So, what's this? 70
and 200
mil. And
then believe this is 500 mil,
right? Yeah. So, this is 500 mil. So 200
mil. Uh we actually do have within 200
mil we've got like
0.9. So we'll see how
uh how this goes. It runs more
experiments. I do think that this one
takes a while to find the good runs.
Right. Let me double check
that. Okay. Yeah. So like this one took
what's this? Like probably 40 50
experiments before it got any that were
this good.
probably that like the first ones it
came up with were uh very long and then
it found shorter ones later. So this is
fine. This is totally
fine. Welcome YouTube
folks. Happy Monday.
So, things to do today because I've got
breakfast in 15ish minutes, but I think
the plan today should be update all the
ends.
Um, and then start working on docs
around that. Actually, I'm going to see.
Let me just at
bet observation issues for Python M's in
dev.
Let me go see your Is it this thing?
issue? So, this seed thing is just it
needing a seed.
So
doing. So all I have to do for this is
that. All
run mini
grid.
error. And I I do have to make sure this
installs with the right
Python, but that's just because I have
weird This broke my
stuff. Thank you for the reports, by the
way. This is all just like, you know,
stuff. I need I do need all these
reports to be able to fix things quickly
because all that happens, right, is I
have to like slice and dice things to
get things clean for release. And I'm
obviously going to break stuff in the
process. Yeah, ideally we can uh I wish
I had better tools for that actually.
Um but yeah, that is on the list as
well.
or should
be. Oh, those aren't even deprecated
imports. They're just changed.
Deprecated would be that I support the
old way of doing it. I just
here. At least this is hitting a spot
where it's supposed to hit, right?
like it's supposed to hit this error if
something is wrong rather than just
randomly
on. Okay. So, this is just that there's
one environment
I actually would like to fix that one
real quick.
I actually think this squeeze is kind of
bad,
huh?
Yeah.
Okay. So, I'm going to have to fix that
uh elsewhere. And I think this is
running like a single
environment dict for obs dype. I don't
get that
update. We really should have config
validation. It's just hard for me to
figure out how to do it.
Well, so now this is should be
reasonable
SPS. Okay, so there's your 30k mini
else. Doesn't break
this. Might screw with the continuous.
We'll see.
type and policy through dict OBS errors.
Oh, I know what that is.
Um, where uh
where do you have uh do you have that
anywhere? Cuz I know what that
is. Oh,
torch. Uh, are you sure you're on the
updated version for that? because that's
not the code that I
have. Yeah. So, uh lean key, I already
fixed that one. That one is already
fixed in dev.
Let me see uh with net hack because I
think I tried this on net hack before
which has nativeized
Yeah, I definitely want Pokemon working
in this. And I do need to do that flush
thing for that guy as well. The uh the
hope with Pokemon is that we're going to
be able to like soda with uh the new
changes. Like our new trainer is really
really really good. We should be able to
soda it.
I do have to run for breakfast in a few
minutes
though. So, we will uh we'll finish that
until I got to go. Um but just for the
other folks watching at the
moment. This is all free and open source
dev. As you can see here, um puffer.ai
for all the details. If you want to help
me out for free, just start the
repository. Really helps. And if you
want to get involved with dev, just join
the Discord. That
easy. And let me see what we can help
Linky
with. You're good. Do what you need
to. Well, I I got a couple minutes, I
think.
Um, just let me know if the current
version works.
I'm sure I broke all the ocean M's.
Like, if you recompile any of the ocean
m, they're all going to break. But
that's on the to-do list today. That's
just straight up like I changed the name
of a couple of functions and I need to
like edit some Okay.
How many actual depths do we have that
we need? I mean, there's just like so
much garbage,
right? I mean, unless you're literally
making numpy like tiny, you need a
numpy. Open CV. We can probably get rid
of Syon. Um, we're almost getting rid
of. We use just Rich is like our
training demo to prettyify some stuff.
These are like standard annoying
things. Uh, so is
this
torch cuz torch this is also torch. So
the only stuff is like psutil and image
io.
Maybe you posted in thread. Let me take
a quick look and then go for breakfast
and then I will be back for the whole
rest of the day with more
dev. Is that on Pokemon
specifically? Yeah.
So, so I'm basically gonna have to run
that specific end to C link key because
native uh dtypes is supposed to be a
dictionary, but for some reason you just
have one
type. You
see like that's supposed to be in a
dictionary.
Um, so yeah, just like remind me or
nudge me around when you're around today
or whenever and uh I'll like get this
thing set up and we'll see why it
doesn't work with uh current puffer and
I'll fix that for
you is 10, right? Yeah. Okay, I'm going
to go for breakfast. Thanks, folks. Star
Repo to help us out, all that.